most of the politicians leading that
campaign know that it's going to make us
poorer but have not said so hello and
welcome to trigonometry I'm Francis
Foster I'm Constance and kitten and this
is a show for you if you're bored with
people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic guest this week is a
former Conservative MP and a columnist
for The Times here in London Matthew
Parris welcome to sugar now hello hello
[Music]
it is so good to have you here let's get
straight into normally we get the guest
to tell us a little bit about themselves
but I think most people will know who
you are it'll all come out in the end as
I was saying to you before we started
the interviews one of the things we try
to do to talk to people from across the
political spectrum who may not be
conventional for the position that they
occupy so we've had a lot of lefty
brexit ears on the show and you are a
right-of-center remainer so tell us what
that's like at the moment well I'm not
of I'm not a far-right I'm
right-of-center and there are actually
an awful lot of right-of-center people
in Britain who don't like the idea of
leaving the European Union where we are
the kind of Forgotten people there and
there are millions of us a 3 million
people voted conservative who also voted
to remain so I don't feel lonely in in
any way but I do feel I'm speaking up
for a section of the British electorate
that has not really been heard that's
why we wanted to have you on the show so
what is the right-of-center argument
against brexit it's basically
conservatism with a small sea leave
things alone unless there's something
terribly wrong with them we've been in
the European Union since when is it 1974
3 I can't remember our economy has been
growing fast in recent years alongside
the economies of the rest of the you
European Union we're still in control of
our own destiny the European Union's
project for a sort of European
super-state is more or less dead now I'm
not convinced the European Union has a
secure future but let's just leave well
enough alone we I'm quite sure we have
an insecure future outside the EU so
what I can't do and lots of my leave
readers are always hitting me with this
question you know what okay you've said
you said why you don't want to leave but
what what's so great about the European
Union tell us what you believe in
because we believe in something we
believe in independence we believe in
taking back control we believe in a
separate destiny for the United Kingdom
what are you believing about Europe I
don't believe in anything about Europe I
just believe that it's chugging along
okay and we're okay and to take this mad
step into into oblivion as far as as for
all we know it's just a very stupid
thing to do it's always hard to be the
sceptical one the one who thinks let's
not do this when there isn't anything
else in particular that you do want to
do but I say let's not do this and now
people always talk about No Deal and
they always use terms like crashing out
and all the rest of it and I still don't
know what wouldn't No Deal mean for this
country if on the 31st of October we
decide to leave without a deal what are
the long-term implications of that well
the the immediate consequence of leaving
without a deal is that we would then
have to negotiate a deal because we have
to have an arrangement with all the
countries around us one of one kind or
another
so any idea that we're not going to have
a deal is is for the birds the only
question is do we try and get a
satisfactory deal before we leave or do
we just leave and then put ourselves in
the position of a supplicant to the
European Union and try to get the best
deal we can the immediate effect of
leaving without a deal would be I think
a bit of a stock market crash it would
be a substantial depreciation and the
value of the pound and it would be an in
idiot contraction of our economy we
could weather that after four or five
years we would get used to being a
country that wasn't in a trading bloc
with anybody else we'd all be a bit
poorer and we'd remain a bit poorer we'd
have a bit less influence and we'd
remain with a bit less influence but the
Sun would continue to rise and set every
day and not many people would die it
would just be a bit [ __ ] really well
it's interesting that you are you you're
quite moderate on both sides I would say
just to interrupt that just reminded me
so much of one of my parents evening
interviews if my taking me along sorry
carry on there's a trigger and moment
for Francis right yeah but you're quite
moderate on it so I'm curious what you
make because I as a remain that or I try
not to call myself for a minute I voted
remain I haven't made it into my
identity is I'm struggling to see how
this language that you see from people
like David Lammy about how everyone
who's who's voted leave is a Nazi or
drgr Nazis are worse than Nazis I don't
see how that extremism helps what do you
make of the language that we now use
when talking about these things I've
learnt sometimes to my cost I I have
learnt that you need to be very careful
what you say about people who voted
leave lots of my friends voted leave
lots of very decent people voted leave
lots of people who are not racists or
xenophobes
or anything else voted leave on the
other hand quite a lot of people who are
racists and of xenophobes
also voted leave on the whole I would
stand back from trying to characterize
leave voters in the United Kingdom with
any overall generalised characterization
they're just 17 million odd different
people each with his or her own story
where I would go in hard is on the
leadership of that campaign and on the
politicians most of the politicians
leading that campaign know that it's
going to make us poorer but have not
said so these are
in the age-old way of politicians people
who are simply capitalizing on the hopes
and fears of a large electorate who
don't know as much about it as they do
it's a sort of confidence trick they are
building their careers
on building up hopes and building up
fears that they the hopes they know will
not be justified and and-and-and-and-and
and the fears are groundless so I I I
dislike and I'm prepared to vilify the
leadership of the leave campaign but as
for the voters themselves they are as
many and various as are all around us so
you're saying so in particular what
would your specific criticisms be of a
figure like Nigel Faraj because on the
one hand you could say that in many ways
one of most talented politicians of his
generation with what he's achieved well
if if by talent you mean the the ability
to whip the mob up and get them on your
side yes he's talented I could name you
a lot of other politicians through
history who were talented in that sense
but he he's the man behind the breaking
point poster do you remember which
suggested hordes of people who are
definitely not white trying to get into
the United Kingdom what what is that if
it's not whipping up popular fears he's
one of the people that pretended that
Turkey was likely to join the European
Union in the foreseeable future
he knows that isn't true it isn't
difficult to get votes by making people
afraid of other people and I have no
neither sympathy nor even grudging
admiration for people who do that well
let me put the counterpoint here on that
because a lot of the people that we've
spoken to many academics experts some
people from the left some people from
the right one of the things they've
talked about is that the break said vote
was to some extent driven by people's
concerns about immigration which I would
argue as an immigrant in this country
were quite legitimate given the labor
boom that we saw in immigration and
given the fact that while we are in the
EU we cannot control that part of our
destiny you said we control our destiny
but that is a part of our destiny that
we absolutely do not control
right hmm we do not control the number
of people who come here no or who comes
here no we don't have any control over
that and you know when I came to this
country in 1995 like 3% of the British
public thought immigration was a major
issue by the mid not what's attends
young boy the mid ted's is a weird it's
a weird name by the mid tens it was
almost 50% yeah because the numbers are
senior something had happened something
had happened right so you could argue
that Nigel Farrar's rather than whipping
up the mob he was responding to the
concerns of ordinary people about the
levels of immigration which were not
being heard in Westminster at the time I
think that's fair to say isn't it yeah
the difference between whipping up and
responding is is actually rather a
newest thing because we are all in echo
chambers and you can amplify and react
Oh to people what you hear from them or
you can try and explain the the true
position but you are absolutely right
that there was widespread anxiety about
the numbers of people coming to Britain
perhaps the then Labor government should
have taken the option that was open to
them to control the numbers coming from
from the EU on the other hand those
people who did exploit those fears and
there is also incipient racism which I
shall not allow you to overlook people
who did exploit that those fears knew
very well that probably the bulk of the
immigrants that that we have and are
getting we we need and that even after
taking back control we probably wouldn't
enormous ly reduce the number of
immigrants coming here but but as I say
I won't let you get away with the idea
that concern about immigration has
nothing to do with racism it does all
across the part of England that was my
constituency the beautiful Derbyshire
Dale's in the in the Peak District that
there are almost nobody but white people
there in fact I remember canvassing a
doorstep canvassing on the doorstep a
man in a very very leafy sort of suburb
who was worried he said black people are
flooding into this country they're all
over the place they're everywhere I said
well I don't think there's any any black
people actually around here and he said
there's one in froggit and froggit being
a place nearby that that that isn't the
same as as concern about immigration and
I I have to say that if this immigration
had been coming from the United States
or Canada or white Australia you
wouldn't have had the anxiety or anger
about it that you did there is a streak
of racism in all of us and there's a
very strong streak of racism in the in
the British people as there is in almost
every people I'm Russia and all but but
actually I I would say to you that well
I think you're right that broadly
speaking everyone has an element there's
that everyone can be potentially racist
this is one of the most open tolerant
and welcoming countries in the world and
it yes yes it's not always a very
competitive field no no when my country
is involved but I just want to explore
this point a little bit because I
understand what you say yeah I think
it's undoubtedly true that there are
some people who are racist and some of
those people would have voted leave on
the basis that you would stop black
people coming to you your constituents
even though black people don't come from
the EU but anyway there may have been
people like that right but some of those
vulgarians are quite son well I don't
consider myself black necessarily but
it's 2018 maybe I should come out yeah
you can identify yeah why not why not
right but on the immigration point the
angle that I'm getting at is the
mainstream politicians were not
listening to people about immigration
and anyone who I remember this very well
anyone in in the mid tense as I keeps
awkwardly saying who expressed any
concern about immigration was
immediately dismissed as being racist
which i think is an unfair complaint you
can be for different levels of
immigration without hating the people
who are coming you may feel that it's
it's hampering integration in this
country you may feel that it's hampering
community cohesion in this country you
may just feel like we've had
a lot of immigration it's time to let
everybody kind of settle down and then
we can open up the door again
so if ordinary people aren't list if
ordinary politicians in the mainstream
aren't listening is it not the job of
someone like Nigel Faraj to come along
and upset things upset the apple cart
because ordinary people aren't having
their voices heard well you could hear
people's voices that's one thing and you
can do what they ask you to do and and
that's another and and we all did hear
the voices of people who felt that
immigration was too high and David
Cameron certainly heard those voices and
when he went for his renegotiation with
the EU he tried really hard to get some
kind of break on immigration and you can
blame Angela Merkel I could blame ankylo
Merkel for not giving him something on
that because she should have the EU
should have and that might have stopped
all this fuss but in the end we can talk
as the media do constantly and as well
as politicians do constantly talk about
listening to people which is one thing
but in the end we have to talk about
what it is that they're saying whether
they're right and whether we want to do
what they're asking us which is why I am
a qualified believer in democracy but I
think it can have some very undesirable
outcomes I mean the whole population
might be saying we want to go to the
moon and politicians might say sorry
sorry but that's not on then you would
say ah but the oh not listening to the
people you're not listening to them
they're saying they want to go to the
moon you're not listening I am listening
I hear they want to go to the moon
unfortunately it is not feasible you've
got you've got to be honest with people
and so we're in this situation right now
where it's political care so I think
it's very s where we're at a crisis
point what do we need to do how can we
possibly solve this in what are the
options well if you want a very general
long-term answer I think we probably got
to smash the two-party system because
both the parties that we've got are
making a terrific mess of it and I don't
quite see how the Labour Party is going
to come back from this and I certainly
don't see how my own
the Conservative Party is going to come
back from it and for that we might have
to move from a first-past-the-post
system to something more proportional
which gave smaller chances a chance to
breathe but in the immediate well what
we got to do is stop brexit and I still
think we can and I still think there's a
decent chance that we will but would you
mean by stopping brexit I mean and also
how would you achieve that is it by a
second reference yeah it would be by a
second referendum it's got to be by a
second referendum you can say as Jeremy
Corbyn does it's got to be or should be
by a general election fine have a
general election but in the end I want a
government that wants us to leave and I
don't think any government I want a
government that wants us to stay yeah
yeah I didn't need to be with the
spectator ages ago a podcast and someone
said so you're saying we're all racists
everyone's racists are you and I said
yes on all the people that troll me on
online commentary say Matthew Parris
believes we're all racist anyway
I want a government that keeps us in the
European Union I don't think any
government could or should do that
without getting endorsement from the
people I want a second referendum
therefore because we've had a referendum
it said leave and if we're not to leave
we got to ask the people their
permission to change our minds what if
they don't give it then we well then we
leave I mean every every nation has a
right to self harm I think my argument
would be that when we said leave as by a
slim majority I don't think we had
really thought through or knew or being
informed of just what that was going to
mean and how difficult it was going to
prove we have been informed of that we
do know if we still say leave if we
still say well we're prepared to crash
out without a deal and take our chances
it
democracy we just have to accept that
and what would you say to those people
so what you are wishing to do of a
second referendum is undemocratic
and you're essentially ignoring my voice
simply because it is not palatable or
mainstream well I would say I'm not
ignoring your voice you can vote in the
second referendum and let's see how many
people vote how many ways you that if
you take a single snapshot of public
opinion in 2016 it won't be long till
that's four years ago you can't then say
it you can never go against that
snapshot opinions change and do you
think it's going to change as well
depending on who the conservative party
elect to be their leader
do you think in terms of Boris Johnson
and Jeremy Hunt I should just say that
we're recording this against weeks
before the video as you know will go out
the day before yes so as people are
watching it we already know or they
already know yeah we don't know now what
do you make of the leadership candidate
well I'm I'm not absolutely certain it's
going to be Boris Johnson I think it's
the overwhelming likelihood is it will
be Boris Johnson but I do know the
ordinary membership of the Conservative
Party the activists of whom I am one the
least active actor and I know that they
adore Boris I know that they love
hearing him speak I know that you can
sell out any dinner with with the ticket
that includes an after-dinner speech by
Boris but I do know also that there's
hardly a conservative member in the
country who doesn't harbor a little bit
of a doubt about whether he has the
competence the concentration the command
of detail and the personal
trustworthiness to be prime minister and
it may be that by the time you hear this
that seed of doubt may have grown and I
think Jeremy Hunt
well he's not mad so he has a chance but
but but but say it's Boris well we've
got to stop him we've got to stop him
leaving the taking us out of the
European Union without at least letting
Parliament vote on it and I believe they
would vote not to so how do you stop
someone like Boris or a vote of no
confidence in the government if there's
time before the 31st of October it's
not clear there is but there might be or
there are various legislative measures
you can vote for that would actually
stop a government taking us out but
Parliament's got got to have the final
say on this when I read an article by by
by you a couple of weeks ago we were
talking about no deal and what I found
quite surprising is that you seemed
almost resigned to your fate at that
point and you were saying I don't think
we're gonna be able to avoid a no deal
but I'm hearing you speak now and you
you seem quite positive about what's
changed I wasn't quite saying that but I
was saying it's not looking good it's
looking as though Boris Johnson could
take us out of the European Union
without a deal I could see it happening
and I'm alarmed about it so to express
alarm it's not quite the same thing as
to express despair I don't I don't yet
despair but I am alarmed it really could
happen I think there's a 30 40 50
percent chance that it's going to happen
now and as a result far from hanging our
heads and weeping we have to fight all
the harder the question I was going to
ask coming back to the democratic point
and I think it is an important one as I
say we've talked to and I talked to a
lot of people who who voted remain but
also a lot of people who vote to live
and what they would be saying is if you
were sitting there now and we'd and we
had voted to remain three years ago
would you be as open to the idea of a
second referendum as you are now that's
a very very sharp question firstly if we
had narrowly voted to remain I have
absolutely no doubt that the leave
people wouldn't simply have packed their
bags and gone home they would be
agitating they might be agitating
immediately for a referendum or they
might be digging in for the long haul
as it were and prepared to push for it
in five 10 15 years time like this and
Peter danske yes and what would I say if
there was a evidence that the European
Union that we'd stayed in was not the
European Union that we thought we were
staying in just as I would say that the
terms of our departure are not the term
of departure we thought we were going to
get what would I say if public opinion
in Britain had swung fairly decisively
against remaining in the European Union
I think I I think I would find it hard
to resist the demand for another
referendum
let's interesting you say the opinion
the Swan I wasn't aware that it had has
opinion swung yes towards remain yes but
it may it might be fifty to forty eight
the other way but is perhaps fifty five
forty five the other way but also
pollsters haven't necessarily covered
themselves in glory in recent no they
haven't but but what we do know is
there's this and I don't mean this in an
unkind way but levers are dying all the
time levers are much older than remain
errs on on balance and and so the actual
composition of the electoral base is
changing and I think has changed and how
much responsibility does the
conservative government and the
Conservative Party have to take for this
whole debacle because part of me
cynically thinks it was just a desperate
attempt to save their own skin really
wasn't it and to keep the party together
it's they have to take complete
responsibility for this de Barker the
Labour Party would never have have done
it it's all the conservative parties
fault it it's not so much a crime of
selfishness or self-preservation it's a
crime of miscalculation
David Cameron wanted to dish the levers
and he felt that renegotiation followed
by a referendum would almost certainly
result in a national vote to remain so
he was using a referendum as a weapon to
clobber his opponents if his calculation
had proved right as it did in Scotland
for instance with their rare friend and
we would all be saying oh what a shrewd
politician he was but the lesson I draw
from this the mistake he made anyone can
miscalculate he did but George Osborne
didn't George Osborne didn't want a
referendum you can miscalculate but you
should never use a referendum to achieve
a
result that you want unless you are
prepared to run with the possibility
that you don't get it and the truth is
that those who call this referendum
believed that our membership of the
European Union was extremely important
to us and that leaving the European
Union would be a very bad thing for the
British people then they shouldn't have
called a referendum because the British
people might have opted for the very
thing that they thought was very bad you
should never opera people a choice or
give people the opportunity to take a
course that you think would be a
disaster it's irresponsible so you're
quite a Peter Hitchens described how
much he when he came to do our show how
much he hated referendum he called them
nasty dirty little things yeah I think
Margaret Thatcher used slightly polite
err language but she hated referendums -
I was gonna ask you're someone who's on
the outside of the political world now
as a journalist but you are a former MP
how how do you feel about you rather be
in there in the trenches stirring the
pot from the inside or did you are you
happier being on the outside and loving
grenades and from the outside I
sometimes feel that it's um it's we of
the media who are in the trenches
lobbing the grenades and the poor bloody
infantry are actually the MPs who are
really just being exploded with grenades
landing or all round them and an are
dazed
and miserable and in some cases almost
suicidal and don't know what to do so
I'd rather be lobbing the
hoo grenades as we are but to answer
your question perhaps slightly more
seriously ever since I left Parliament
ceased to be an MP I have found that
whatever voice I have gets a bigger
audience and has more influence than it
did when I was a backbench MP I don't
think any cabinet minister ever invited
me to dinner when I was a backbench Tory
MP when when you're a columnist in a
national newspaper you get those
invitations all the time that's
fascinating isn't it so what do you
think that essentially
Parliament has little influence now
because of this in terms of how this
goes
or will it still have a big role to play
well I think the ordinary backbencher
has always been a creature whose
importance is exaggerated by the general
public and has never had a huge amount
of power and only ever gets very much
power when there's a very fine balance
between the two parties and a rebellion
on one side or the other can shift the
the dial but they do have that power now
back benchers and I wish they would use
it some of them are there are some very
brave people out there on both sides
actually some very brave people but too
many of them are just kind of covering
their heads well that well that well the
shells land in many ways so you can't
blame them because if you are a remain
MP and that's what you believe is best
for this country and your constituency
vote leave I mean you're in a horrible
situation you're in a very simple
situation you're going to lose your job
so you have to be really brave to do
that
I'd agree a huge courage is called for
and some have shown it David Gork the
justice secretary showed it and was
challenged in his constituency but
luckily survived dominic grieve has been
challenged so far he has survived plenty
of others know very well that they're
not going to be Reis elected because
their leave constituency associations
disapprove of having a remain MP yeah it
takes guts
well I listen to this sorry Francis with
with the lever hat on because we've been
talking to a lot of levers and I can
hear exactly what they would be saying
now which is look we elect these people
to represent us how is it that you're
sitting here as a former MP and saying
basically the MP should ignore the will
of his constituency and show courage by
doing the opposite of what they want MPs
are not delegates they are not presented
with a list of things that their
constituents want them to do voted in on
the basis of their promising to do those
things and then absolutely obliged to do
those things I think the things that you
have in your manifesto the things which
your party has promised
you you have a solemn duty to look very
hard and do your best to achieve what
people want but if you come to the
conclusion that it can't be done or that
it can't be done without grave damage to
the very people who have sent you there
then your final responsibility is to
your own judgment and to your own
conscience where we have a system of
representative democracy not not a lot
of mandated Manifesto commitments well
to me that sounds like a very strong
event for a general election now because
we have two parties that ran on leaving
the EU neither of which is seems to
prepare to implement that so should we
not have a general election to to elect
a new Parliament of people who better
represent the public's wishes I think I
think there's a very strong argument for
a general election basically the
government's completely buggered you
know this reminds me of watching labour
and conservatives I'm a West Ham fan and
sometimes we pray at another team and
work both teams on the pitch are
absolutely crap and you just saw I think
it's just not this on their head yeah
because you're both useless yeah
and it's come to the point I mean how
much responsibility do do labour have to
take they have an open goal against this
government in in every possible way and
they still can't seem to capital because
their leader doesn't doesn't doesn't
want to remain Jeremy Corbyn has always
hated the European Union if you're a
proper Marxist you ought a union it is a
capitalist club he's he's absolutely
right about that and so that right right
at the very top Jeremy Corbyn I think
Seamus Milne who's an extremely powerful
right hand person there's a little group
there who a would like Britain not to be
in the European Union so when we have as
they believe a socialist government
it'll be free to do the socialist things
the EU wouldn't let it and be don't want
to be blamed for the pain that would
cause well then it's perfect doesn't it
get the Tories to take us out blame the
Tories but we're out we're out and
that's that's that's what a Marxist
would want so do you think he wants a
general election or do
would he prefer us to leave and then
trigger it I think if you're 70 you
probably want to general election as as
quickly as possible but I do think the
results of that general election might
be devastating both for the Labour Party
and the Conservative Party and I just
don't care anymore I think probably
devastation would be the beginning of
reconstruction I think that is so true
and I think you speak for a lot of
people when you say that I think there's
so many people now who are so fed up of
the two-party system because it doesn't
represent what the people want and I
think devastation is a right word
because what you likely end up with
certainly is a large brexit party mmm
Block in parliament the Conservatives
would and labor would lose quite a lot
of avoids to them and the Greens might
get a few seats and you know you might
get the Lib Dems might be making
surgeons yeah right
how do if we were to have a general
election in the next six months I mean
it's hard obviously to make these
predictions because we don't even know
who the leader of the Tory Party is
going to be but what do you think would
happen what that devastation that you
talk about more would it look like I
don't know the I think it's a socialist
thinker Marxist philosopher Gramsci who
said that the old is dying but the new
is struggling to be read to be born and
I think the new is struggling to be born
look at the poor old tickers the
independent group for instance said it
was a little bit of a stillbirth that
one so I don't know what the consequence
would be but I think it probably would
be the fragmentation of the two-party
system that we have at the moment and it
is literally pointless to try to predict
how that fragmentation would
fragmentation would then pan out but I
think this thought is worth putting
across the next general election will
not be a matter of whether you gov is
saying that this party is on 28 percent
this is on 26 percent this is 119 all
the Tories have gone up to 32 it won't
be that sort of an election it will be
an election in which no one party
predominates and no one party challenges
and in a first-past-the-post system such
as we have parties may get in on
on tiny votes as the Labour Party just
did squeaked through the lowest vote in
history I think in the Peterborough
by-election it will all be about
electoral pacts it will all be about
tactical voting
it will all be about constituency by
constituency which party can split the
vote of which other party and in those
circumstances us pontificating or
philosophizing over the overall result
is is futile guys we wanted to take a
moment to say thank you to every single
one of you that has supported us on
patreon subscribe star that sent us
money through PayPal we could not do the
show without you please keep supporting
us and if you haven't already please
consider doing so because that is
exactly what allows us to keep improving
the show every single week having said
that we've now also got a corporate
sponsor to sell out to indeed we have
and it is the magazine the week and what
the week does is it pulls together the
best articles from over 200 different
sources from publications such as The
Times The Telegraph or our one liberal
snowflake fan their Guardian they do
exactly what we do on the show which is
pull together balanced opinions from
different sides so that you can make
your own mind up and you don't get stuck
in an echo chamber and if you want to
take advantage of this special offer all
you need to do is go to the weak co dot
uk' slash offer use our special code
trigger and you'll get six free issues
of the week the great thing about the
week is that allows you to read less and
know more which is going to appeal to
people like Francis who can barely read
and it's not just news the week also
brings you the latest from the world of
sports so if you want to find out what's
going on in the transfer window who
mentor United are gonna sign the week
will also deliver you the latest
freshest news on that which one appealed
to someone like Constantine because he's
a massive virgin well anyway guys
seriously we know that you've got busy
lives we understand that you're not
going to be reading 200 articles a week
and that's what the magazine does it
brings together those articles in a one
combined easy package that you can read
and know what's going on join thousands
trust the week as their essential
curator
new source try for yourself and get your
first six issues completely free to take
advantage of this great offer visit the
week code UK forward slash offer enter
our code which is of course trigger and
get your first six issues completely
free we've talked a lot about brexit and
the European Union Oh someone made a
very very good point that one of the
problems with braces is it stopped us
from discussing other matters which are
equally if not more important the
Conservative Party has always marketed
itself as a party of law and order we
will you know invest in police we'll
have a strong police presence I still
teach in East London and knife crime is
out of control how much responsibility
do the conservative party have to take
for this I agree that Laura Laurent
order is important and I agree your
characterization of the conservative
party's stance I don't think that simply
paying police officers more or
recruiting a lot more officers on the
beat is the answer to the problem I
think the problem is one that any
government but particular Conservative
government is going to find difficult to
tackle I think there is a problem in the
underlying competence of the British
police force or forces I don't think we
should have so many Constabulary I I
think we should have a national police
force I think we should have a separate
police force for dealing with internet
crime as we do for instance were they
with the Transport Police I think we
should look at the way we recruit police
officers some should be paid more some
should be paid less it should be easier
to fail as a police officer and to lose
your job as a police officer a huge
problem of reforming a huge campaign a
project of reforming our national police
force should be a priority of any
government but I think the Conservative
Party will tend just to slip into the
the old the the old tropes have we need
more bobbies on the beat we need another
2000
eastman by next July or whatever and it
won't make any difference on knife crime
i I think knife crime is a is a kind of
fat fad it's a kind of fashion now it
sounds I know
cruel it sounds as though I'm trying to
diminish the the horror of knife crime
I'm not and the horror is I don't need
to explain the horror it's it's very
real to everybody but things do go in
fashions including horrible things go in
fashions and it is at the moment
a bit like a virus a bit like a disease
sweeping through certain kinds of
younger people and I'm not sure that
simply flooding the streets with police
officers is necessarily going to make
much of a difference I know it sounds
feeble to say what we need is education
but what we do need to do is talk to
people talk to younger people try to try
to communicate try to engage and try to
put persuade I'm not sure that law and
order alone will solve this well people
we've had different people on the show
to talk about knife crime one of the one
of them was dr. Tony Sol who does a lot
of work and in that in the area and
bringing young kids from those
backgrounds through to apply to Oxford
and Cambridge and one of the points he
made it was about the breakdown of the
family there's not a new fathers in the
home to to teach young men young boys
the way of the world essentially so
that's one aspect of it but you could
argue I mean Peter Hitchens made this
point on our show and I find a very
persuasive that it's also about police
tactics if you have the situation we
have now I remember when I first came to
this country 20 or more than 20 years
ago it was a common occurrence that
you'd be walking down the street and
there would be a police officer walking
towards you who was just patrolling the
street they were just on the street
walking around creating a visual
deterrent to crime I have not I think I
probably haven't seen a police officer
doing that in years you see police
officers going to a crime scene going
from a crime scene but the idea that you
just walking down the street in your
town and you see a Bobby on the beat I
don't think that happens anymore
as I understand it beat policing is is
not something that
the great majority of police officers
want to end up doing for much of their
their lives and it isn't always just the
government or the Home Secretary
it is something sometimes the police
themselves who prefer to be in pander
cars than on the beat nevertheless the
police do have an argument which I think
we ought to take seriously which is we
could never have so many police officers
that their visibility would be almost
everywhere cooling and and and and
calming and discouraging crime that the
numbers involved would be too great we
can find places which are hot spots and
make sure there are police officers
there but I'm not sure that numbers of
visible policemen these days is most of
the answer and how much of the
responsibility again to the Conservative
Party need to take with austerity with
the cuts coming in particularly cuts to
youth workers it cuts to youth clubs you
know a lot a lot of people have actually
said that this has been one of the prime
reasons why it's there's been a spike I
was in favor of austerity and I still AM
I think it was necessary
however I I think the government the
conservative first the coalition and
then the Conservative government went
for the line of least resistance the
easy target which is local government
because you can cut local government and
they have by you know up to 50 percent
and the immediate effects don't show and
you say wow we're giving them 50 percent
less money and and the world carries on
everything's everything's the same and
it takes a while because of things like
looking looking after the elderly
looking after young people youth groups
all kinds of little things that local
government does to try to spot where the
problems are and to help when you begin
to draw back from those things it takes
a while for it to show and it is
beginning to show and I think it's a
sign that austerity went too quickly for
the soft target so what in particular
what would you have targeted rather than
local government because my a lot of my
family working
government and they say the cuts have
been absolutely devastating to the point
where they can only give the very basic
of services and everything else it's
just so you simply can't deliver well I
might have taxed a little bit more which
is a kind of austere austerity and I I I
might have held back on pensions
increases the the those of retired aged
in Britain now which which includes me
are no longer the poorest section of the
community we are doing pretty well I I
came here with my my Freedom Pass my
London Freedom Pass elbowing aside young
people or unemployed people I'm probably
earning 10 times what they're earning so
typical Tory so why were you in favor of
austerity because I don't think that's
an argument that that gets heard very
much why was it necessary and why were
you we were living beyond our means and
you can't live beyond your means forever
and how do you in particular
what was it could you pinpoint something
that an example of how we were living
beyond our means how we were spending
far too much well if you're spending
more than than you're earning you could
you can look at any item of your
expenditure and see that it would need
to be reined back and III mentioned
pensions as one example the Frances is
from Venezuela he and and saving well so
it was necessary because we were
spending beyond that is an argument I
absolutely get to be honestly I think I
look at our deficit look at our national
debt it means crazy yeah and look now
that the promises that the Tory
leadership candidates have been making
they seem to have completely forgotten
what I thought was a core conservative
philosophy that we should live within
our means and what are they promising so
Francis what is it that you're concerned
about in terms of that well Boris has
been talking about tax cuts for the the
top level or raising the threshold he's
been talking about more money on
education he's been talking about more
money for the police Jeremy Hunt I can't
remember how many
things Jeremy hunters and a lot more on
defense for instance I mean all these
are good things but you you can't just
will good things without willing the
means to pay for the good things well
you've had your bash of Boris what do
you make of Jeremy hunt just in case he
gets elected tomorrow when this video I
don't think he exists I think he's a
hologram
III I long to just put my hand and see
if it goes right through I don't feel as
a real person there I'm I suppose I'd
have to vote for him because he's he's
neither mad not nor wicked nor stupid
he's a focused individual a good manager
as far as I can see but where's where's
the personality where's the where's the
the sense of of core values of principle
he's he seems to shift every time the
wind shifts I was about to say if you
want personality by Boris but then you
started talking about values but it's
interesting to me that you say that
because it's I think it shows to what
extent politics and particularly
choosing a leader of a party or leader
of a country is such a visceral
animalistic thing almost because I don't
I didn't know much about Jeremy Han and
then I watched the hustings and he had
this little video talking about his
career people talking about what he'd
done for them how he created this
business I mean he's actually had a very
accomplished career he's someone who's
created a lot he's that started
companies you know he took care of one
of the most difficult departments to
manage in government in her in in in
health and of course many people
criticize him for her but also he did
some good things than that and yet you
look at him and you go well you just a
bit bland and that is enough to condemn
someone to essentially not be prime
ministerial yes but you you you could
talk to people at the top of many of
service industries in the media public
relations all those things and you will
find plenty of Jeremy Hunt like
characters who have done very well and
who have worked their way to the top by
being bland
he's a smooth operator he's definitely a
smooth operator and it will get you so
far
in politics being a smooth operator and
he's a hard worker a very hard worker
and I I went talk to him about health
once when he was health secretary and I
I was impressed at the the grip the
intellectual grip he has on the whole
thing
but these are managerial skills and you
need managerial skills Boris has no
managerial skills but you need something
more than manager jereal skills and I'm
not convinced that he has them but we
may see them maybe there's a new
butterfly Jeremy Hunt is going to emerge
from the chrysalis isn't there something
to be said though that we've you know
we've done personality politics to death
you know we've elected somebody who is
you know you know he's charismatic or
whatever else ultimately what we need
now is somebody who can just get the job
done and if that is the case we have to
be pragmatic and we have to just say you
know Boris great you who make you laugh
you know if he's a comedian you get him
to close the Comedy Store and you know
and have you rolling in the aisles
applause breaks all the rest of it but
if you want someone to get the job done
and be consistent you don't want to
demean I don't disagree with you the
first thing that we've got to have is
someone who can get things done I'm a
great believer in the value the values
of public administration sound public
administration politicians talk about
vision they talk about change they talk
about being the change walking the walk
all this kind of crap they forget that
the first thing you have to do is run an
extremely complicated state it's like
being the governor of a colony you have
to run things and I think probably
Jeremy Hunt does have those abilities
but I've suggested that in order to keep
people with you to keep a nation with
you especially through difficult times
you need something more than that
something in addition to that and and
just going back to Theresa May because
there was a part of me I've never voted
conservative in my life and you know but
there was a part of me that felt in the
end quite sorry for how bad a job did
she do she did a really bad job and
and you shouldn't be here you shouldn't
feel sorry for I know it's all once
people are down you don't want ya kick
in but she what what her big failure was
to explain both to her own party and to
the British people just how difficult
what it was we were trying to do which
was leave the European Union was going
to be an instead she went storming in at
the beginning with all these red lines
and promises and all that was was red
meat to the irresponsible right in her
own party and it all ran away with her
well math it's on that optimistic note
we've got time for one more question
which is a question that we always ask
which is what is the one thing that no
one is talking about that we ought to be
talking about
there was a feminist called
I think Valerie Solana who said the only
purpose of men is to produce sperm
fortunately we have sperm banks might my
great fear generations will notice what
the animal world noticed a long time ago
which is that you don't need many males
just enough males to fight with each
other to sort of keep evolution going
but you don't need nearly as many males
as you do females and women haven't
noticed this or women really would need
would be a sperm bank and and sex toys
they don't need us and we certainly
don't need a population which is 50%
male so we're having a marvelous time
because no one has noticed that we're
unnecessary okay I think yeah well
that's why I make Matthew thank you so
much for coming on we're really
appreciating your on Twitter at I'm I'm
not you know I don't know it's I follow
Twitter I am I'm on it but I never tweet
okay I don't I don't trust myself
well you don't follow Matthew on Twitter
then just read this column it's always
very interesting follow us on Twitter we
are on Twitter we still feel like
where necessary somewhere so follow us
at trigger pod on all the social media
and subscribe to the YouTube channel as
always click the bell button next to
subscribe button and we will see you in
a week from now and yes and you always
forget nice fine man are you sure yeah
it's fine
I'm gonna sell out my show in Edinburgh
anyway it's called or well there as well
I've sold a lot of tickets already if
you want to come please do hurry up okay
that's a great marketing move I haven't
sold any tickets no he really hasn't
seriously I know I've seen this out
anyway if you want to come and see me
I'm at the Bill Murray comedy club an
angel in August and July check out check
out the website for details if you enjoy
the show please share it please tell a
friend
leave us a nice review on iTunes it was
particularly if you were in the United
States or abroad because that helps us
get global coverage oh and that is
pretty much it thank you so much for
watching and listening and we will see
you next week bye bye
[Music]
here's the four that you were asked to I
said by signing this contract this is a
UNICEF on campus SOAs right it was asked
to sign an agreement that is routine
would not contain racism sexism classism
ageism ableism homophobia biphobia
transphobia xenophobia Islamophobia
anti-religion anti atheism I think
you're doing some quite complicated
mental arithmetic to offset the party
people didn't think you were funny
performing autopsies recover
you have absolutely no sense of humor do
you feel like you just I mean you're
just so paying a bevin outright you know
all right that we got there in the end
you didn t do you the good thing about
people thematic needed right as i know
got a niche problem is I haven't got any
racist sexist homophobic jokes have been
a student at the University where you
can't make any joke about anything if
these poor little white students get
upset will trigger get over yourselves
it's not about comedy it's about
ordinary people up and down the country
in here in Britain and in America
feeling like they can't say what they
think I really don't know I get it I get
it especially especially the women who
want to become in bail right when from
talking to real madrid the guy left a
perfectly good club for more money
everybody feels like we're we're all
kind of under arrest we're all all
everything we say can and will be used
against us in the court of public
opinion and can they're coming for the
comedians first because we're we're the
ones that is you say are allowed to
transgress but everybody else feels it
and that's why the stories got the resin
and so it has
you
[Music]